the Kilauea volcano in Hawaii destroyed
hundreds more homes in - oh Sh in front
communities dramatic aerial video shows
rivers of lava spewing from the volcano
the massive flows wiped out the
communities of capo ho and vacation land
nearly all of the 490 homes are believed
to have been lost these two pictures
were taken just two days apart Wow the
lava filled in all of Kapoho Bay
extending nearly a mile from the
coastline Lonnie Quinn chief weather
caster of our New York station WCBS
shows us how Kilauea compares to the
volcano in Guatemala
Lonnie good morning well volcan de fuego
in Guatemala and Kilauea in Hawaii are
both volcanoes but they are very
different volcan de fuego is a composite
volcano so this looks like your typical
volcano it's tall it's steep it's over
12,000 feet tall
Kilauea is a shield volcano so it's
shorter it's fatter it's only about
4,000 feet tall and in Hawaii most of
the eruptions have happened when that
lava has traveled 30 miles underground
and it breaks through the earth at a
number of different openings composite
volcanoes on the other hand these will
erupt violently and primarily out of
that one main vent and the lava in
Hawaii that's causing all the damage is
founding at about well maybe say 250
feet in the air and that's because all
of that pressure it's spread out through
a number of different openings it's got
a consistency kind of like thick maple
syrup and it travels slowly this only
moves that are maybe half a mile per
hour the eruption from broken to Fuego
entirely different it reached 47,000
feet in the air you've got to think of
this as a flash flood it's filled with
rocks and ash and it just speeds down
that mountain at over 50 miles per hour
and outrunning something like this is an
absolute impossibility and people die
when they can't escape it because it is
over a thousand degrees and it is going
to burn or it's going to destroy
everything in its path now eventually
this turns it's like a dense kind of mud
and one thing that both these volcanoes
have in common the dangers not done yet
okay at volcan de fuego if it rains that
dense mud is going to cause these these
landslides called lahars and they can be
incredibly dangerous and Kilauea the
eruptions just continue and the
scientists think they could continue for
another month
if not two months more John Lonnie
thanks I feel like I just went to my
favorite science class yeah great
explanation